Hi Everyone,
and thank you for coming.
Um,
today,
Authors Jorge Cham and Daniel Watson will be telling us everything they do not
know about their new book.
We have no idea.
Um,
Jorge Cham is the creator of the popular online comic,
piled higher and deeper,
also known as phd comics.
He earned his phd in robotics at Stanford.
Daniel Watson is a professor of experimental particle physics at the University
of California,
Irvine and a fellow of the American physical society.
He conducts research using the large Hadron collider at cern.
Please take a moment to silence your cell phones and anything else that will
beat and then join me in welcoming Daniel and Jorge.
Okay.
Hello.
How's it going?
Okay,
so it sounded very excited.
I'll try it.
Yeah.
All right.
Not much better,
but,
uh,
we'll take what we can get.
Well,
first of all,
thank you to Google for inviting us here today.
Um,
we are very excited and I will tell you exactly how excited I am,
but a Google probably already knows everything about me,
so there's no reason to tell you.
Cool.
Well,
my name is Jorge Cham.
Uh,
as mentioned in my cartoonists and does this professor Daniel Weitzman from the
University of California at Irvine and I together with the coauthors of this
book called,
we have no idea which is about all the things we don't know about the universe.
Uh,
now today I'm gonna talk to you a little bit about how our collaboration
started,
how we got together and wrote this book.
And then Daniel will take over and he'll talk to you actually about what's in
the book.
Now I'm a cartoonist.
And to me being a cartoon ace it cartoon is,
it's about taking a blank page and filling it with an idea.
And so the idea we want to draw out for all of you here today is this idea that
there are still big gaps in our knowledge of the universe.
Now,
in addition to being a cartoonist,
I also happened to have a phd in robotics.
Now you might be wondering,
but us having a phd in robotics have to do with being a cartoonist.
Well,
I can tell you that my parents were also very concerned about that whole life
plan.
Um,
but my,
I have a phd in robotics from Stanford.
I actually just down the street and in fact my research,
they're focused on making robots that could run,
they could run and walk like animals can in nature.
And in particular I focused on making robots.
I could run like cockroaches.
Yeah.
So here's a quick movie of what these robots look like.
No.
Yeah.
I like to show this movie at all my presentations for two reasons.
First of all,
I feel like this movie really kind of represents what getting a phd feels like.
Hey,
some of you might know the feeling,
you feel like you're running frantically the whole time that you're not getting
anywhere.
Meanwhile,
there's a more intelligent being stamping you down.
I know,
but I was like to show it because it's really kind of the only way that it's one
of the only way that anyone will look at my research.
Thank you.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Cause I,
it seemed a little bit more popular than the research I spend years working on
as part of my actual career.
A little bit more popular has been what I was doing when it should have been
doing research when I was procrastinating,
which were some make these comic strips called pile tire and deeper or phd
comics.
And these are comics that I just started writing as a graduate student.
It was my first year,
uh,
at Stanford and I just,
I kind of wrote about what it was like to start in a phd program and find a
place in a lab.
All the begging you have to do.
I also kind of wrote about what it's like to be a teaching assistant,
right?
Dealing with those annoying undergraduates.
We don't have any here today.
Do we any interns snow?
Oh,
I'm sure you're a cool show.
You are here.
You must be cool.
Uh,
let's see.
The comics were also about learning about Grad student etiquette.
Well,
you should never ask a Grad student how,
how's your research going go?
So I just Kinda kept drawing these comics and then one day I decided to take my
procrastination to the next level and I started posting these on a free web
server on campus.
And as most things,
like there's like these happen,
uh,
on the Internet,
you know,
somebody read it on campus and liked it and then they told their friends and
they knew in other universities about this website and then they,
they told their friends and their lab mates and those people told other people
in other universities.
Uh,
and so slowly over the years,
these comics kind of spread out into the world,
kind of like a,
like a virus,
uh,
to the point where about six or 7 million people a year come through the phd
comics website,
which is a,
an incredibly small number.
If you think about the fact that there are about 7 billion people on this
planet.
So there's about a 0.1% chance that you've ever heard of me before I walked into
this room.
Uh,
but it just so happened that one of those,
uh,
millions of people who went to their website was a professor at the university,
University of California at Irvine,
who saw these comics and he decided to email me one day out of the blue.
I just get this email in my inbox saying,
hey,
Jorge,
I senior comics online,
I think they're pretty good.
Um,
can I commission you?
Can I pay you to write some comics about the Higgs Boson?
Now,
this was a few years ago.
Uh,
where would,
there was a lot of attention in the media being paid to this discovery that
people were searching for the Higgs Boson and Daniel,
the professor didn't think that people are doing a good job of explaining what
this interesting and complex phenomenon was and how people were looking for it.
So he decided to contact me and offer to commission me to make a something that
explained what it was.
And so I thought,
what
you want to pay me?
What is that?
I don't understand.
I just put things on the Internet for free.
Uh,
so I said yes.
And so I went down and I interviewed him and we had a conversation over lunch at
the cafeteria and instead of taking notes,
I kind of broaden my recorder and I recorded our conversation.
And then when I went home to draw these commies,
I decided to experiment a little bit.
Uh,
and so I took the audio from the recordings and I recorded myself drawing the
comics and it kind of put those things together.
And we made a video in addition to the comics
and,
uh,
we decided to take this video and we posted it on this website.
You may have heard of it.
It's called uh,
Youtube.
Uh,
and so now I'll just clay for you guys a one or two minutes,
a clip,
one or two minute clip from this video,
just so you kind of get a sense of how our collaboration started.
So here's a,
here's a clip from the video.
One of the things people would predict is the Higgs Boson,
the Higgs Boson is the part of that is responsible for giving mass to the other
part of this.
You think of,
think of something happen then asked me to have stuff to it.
It's not actually stuff.
Earlier I was saying electron has mass,
it has no volume happened.
There'd be,
it turns out the mass is probably just characteristic of a particle of the way
like charges,
but some verticals have charged electrons,
some particles don't.
It's just a different kind of chart so you can think of mass and sort of
gravitational charge.
And when two things have both have mess,
they a attract each other.
You just in that you can't have negative mass or repulsive gravity
press.
The collision happens.
It lasts for like 10 to the negative 23 seconds and you get one measurement,
right?
So if you say,
well,
I'm going to plot the mass,
the total energy of this game,
and add this guy and he's got together and had the total energy.
This is a,
this one axis here is number of collisions.
You're individual experiment,
you get one measurement right here.
Another one,
you get another measurement,
you do another one.
Eventually you build up your data and the data looks like this,
for example.
And then you have two theories,
right?
The predictive data one says,
well,
I'm going to predict there's no Higgs Boson,
so the data should fall along this line.
The other is I'm a pretty cat plus a Higgs Boson.
And the problem is the difference between these two theories is very small.
And so that it's very hard to distinguish these two with our data because the
predicted effect is tiny,
right?
If the predicted effect were huge,
it'd be very easy to tell the difference between with expose on or not with expo
site,
but the predicted effect is tiny.
And so it's really hard to see.
What you need is a huge amount of data.
You need to take a bajillion collisions before you can see the difference.
That's why we run this thing 40 million times a second all day,
all year to get a lot of collisions to tell the small differences between
theories.
It's like when you take a picture of the sky,
we just take a picture.
You get a little bit of light.
The longer you leave your telescope looking at the sky,
the more you can see farther away things.
I get a call.
That was the video.
So we posted this online.
Um,
and then it just so happened that a few months later they actually discovered
the Higgs Boson.
And so when they discovered that there was a huge amount of attention paid on
this from the media and the popular press and this video set of went viral,
millions of people watch this video.
And a lot of people were pointing to this video as a clearest and easiest to
understand explanation of what this kind of complex phenomenon was and how
people were looking for it and,
and why,
especially why they were looking for it.
So I thought that was pretty cool that,
you know,
the clearest and easiest to understand explanation didn't come from the New York
Times media department.
It didn't come from some,
uh,
you know,
some,
uh,
professional,
company or animators.
It came from actually one of the scientists who worked on the project,
who decided to take the initiative and commissioned an artist and work with them
to create something that explained this to the public.
So I thought that was pretty cool.
Uh,
so since then we've worked on a couple of other projects together,
but our latest project is this book called we have to idea,
uh,
now to talk to you about the ideas inside of,
we have no idea is Daniel Watson.
Hello everyone.
Uh,
and thanks Jorge.
So,
uh,
before I get started,
I have to correct Jorge's story a little bit.
He's a overly modest when he tells that anecdote.
Um,
if any of you have been in academia that you know,
that Jorge's not just a cartoonist,
he's sort of a celebrity.
Um,
I go around and visit lots of physics labs and the almost every single wall
there is one of Jorge's cartoons cause he's really captured the suffering of the
graduate students.
Um,
so he's really a super well known.
And when I was thinking about how to explain physics using cartoons,
I thought,
well,
who could possibly have both the artistic skills and the technical understanding
to communicate these difficult topics?
Right.
And so my wife,
who is also a huge fan of a phd comics said,
why don't you email Jorge Tom and ask him to do it?
And I thought,
sure.
Yeah.
And then I'll eat,
write an email the Brad Pitt and ask him to do,
make a movie about me also.
Right.
Like just as likely to be successful.
But a,
Brad hasn't gotten back to me about the movie.
Um,
but I had the great pleasure of working with Jorge on project.
did you're Brad Pitt in this scenario?
I like it.
Yeah.
Um,
so our book is called,
we have no idea.
And instead of being another science book that explains what science has figured
out,
that focuses of this book is not about what we don't know all the things that we
don't know about the universe.
So if you come to hear a talk from an author,
you expect them to be an expert on the topic or I mean real authority.
So you might be wondering,
well,
what's this guy's expertise?
Like not having ideas or something,
you know?
And so it doesn't sound so great to claim that I'm an expert in our level of
cosmic ignorance,
but that's sort of the situation.
And you might wonder,
well,
why write a book about the things we don't know?
And it's not that I want to celebrate our ignorance.
There's plenty of that going on already.
It's,
it's that I want to convince you that in science,
ignorance is opportunity.
It's an opportunity to make discoveries because when you know what you don't
know,
then you know where to look and how to answer these questions.
Okay?
And so what I wanted to do,
and what we hope to do in this book is to introduce you to are staggering cosmic
level of ignorance,
to prepare you for all the awesome discoveries that we think are coming around
the corner.
Okay?
Because it's when you can confront your ignorance,
when you could,
then you know how to,
how to look for the answers,
you know,
how to begin your exploration and the end.
It's really about the exploration.
And when I was a kid,
I thought the age of exploration sounded like a lot of fun.
I mean,
all you had to do discover something new back then was jumping the ship,
sail across the ocean and land on a new beach.
Right?
You can be the first person to ever walk on a beach or eat a new kind of fruit
or something,
right?
These were amazing first in human history.
And I wanted one,
you know,
imagine like the first person to ever see the Grand Canyon,
right?
There was a first person they've got to do that or the first person to ever eat
chocolate,
right?
That wasn't experience.
Well,
the first person ever eat chocolate while looking at the Grand Canyon,
right?
These are all important first in human history.
And I wanted it to be the first person to know something or do something or see
something,
right?
Um,
but as you're reading about the age of exploration that's happened hundreds of
years ago,
you know,
there aren't any more new content,
continents to discover or a islands to land on a name after your poodle,
right?
Um,
and thanks to,
you know,
Google Earth for example,
it's very difficult to,
uh,
to say that there's anything left to explore.
And the more you look around you,
you,
the more you get to feeling like,
well,
not only have we explored and map the surface of the earth,
we've also really started to master technical things and the way things work,
right?
I mean we have amazing things,
uh,
airplanes that could fly over oceans and download all of human knowledge into a
little device that fits in your pocket.
Right?
You know,
a,
you can make $1 billion off of a single idea.
I mean,
it's a,
it's truly a crazy modern world we live in.
It's an age of wonders.
Okay.
So you might get the sense that science has mostly figure things out that were
just,
have a few little details to wrap up and then we're basically done understanding
of the universe.
Well,
the point I want to make to you today and the point in our book is that exactly
the opposite is true.
That in fact we were at the beginning of a new age of exploration,
an ex,
an era of exploration that I hope will reveal staggering,
crazy ideas about the universe that currently we have no idea about.
Okay.
So what do I mean age of exploration?
Like how can,
how is it possible to explore things we've had?
We've had such a deep understanding of the universe.
Well,
the kind of exploration I'm talking about is the kind of where we ask big
questions.
Okay?
Really big fat,
juicy,
basic,
ancient,
deep questions.
The kind of questions that everybody wants to know the answer to,
right?
The really big fat questions,
the questions,
which if you knew the answer,
it would change the way you felt about your place in the universe and the human
situation.
You know,
these kinds of big questions.
All right,
so let's be concrete about it.
What kind of questions am I talking about?
Well,
you went down the hallway and ask a random person,
what are the most important questions in life?
They might say things like this,
right?
Well,
why are we here?
That's a big one,
right?
Uh,
what happens after we die?
Also an important question.
If I knew the answer to that question,
am I changed the way I live my life or treat people?
Right?
These kinds of really deep,
big questions.
Another popular one is what is it like to be a bat,
right?
This is a question people think about some times and the co the,
the interesting thing about these questions is that while they are deep
questions and important questions,
they're also philosophy questions,
which means that you can spend a lot of time thinking about them and arguing
about them and not necessarily make any progress.
Right?
Even if you smoke banana peels for 20 years and go down to the philosophy
department,
you might not figure it out and you might think this last one,
what is it like to be a bat?
You might think that's just a joke.
It's actually the title of the most widely cited philosophy paper of all time.
Okay.
People are still arguing about what it's like to be a bat and I think they're
never going to figure it out and that's the problem with philosophy questions.
They're important.
They're deep.
I don't mean to dismiss philosophy,
but they don't have objective answers.
Okay.
The cool thing to me is that there are other questions,
questions just as deep,
just as ancient,
just as important,
but these are science questions.
Great questions like this.
What is everything made out of?
How did the universe begin?
Okay,
the universe has one true history.
It began in a certain way and no other way,
and if you knew that story,
here's how the universe began.
Here's what came before the big bang.
Here's what caused the big bang.
You would feel differently about though the about our lives and the way we live
it in the future,
right?
These are important questions at the same level.
The cool thing is these questions if answers right,
there is a true factual answer to these questions and we can discover it.
If we do the right experiment and put together the right pieces and the clues,
we could actually learn the answer after which no matter how many banana peels
you smoke,
no reasonable people can disagree anymore about the answers,
right?
Unfortunately,
we can include like the u s government and the list of reasonable people anymore
because they don't listen to science.
But you know,
people who will listen to science and accepted the objective truths can actually
agree on the answers to big,
deep and ancient questions.
To me that's incredible and that's the kind of exploration that I'm talking
about.
Okay,
so let's zoom in on one of these questions.
This one here is the one that I spend my professional life working on.
What is the universe made out of?
And this is really a basic and a reasonable question.
I mean,
if you wake up,
it's like a conscious being in the world.
You look around you and you ask,
what am I made out of?
What was he met out of?
What does,
how does everything put together?
What are the rules?
Right?
What is the most basic element of matter?
How is this whole thing work?
It's an ancient question,
basic question.
And I think a reasonable one,
2100 the answer to,
I remember as a kid smashing rocks together and seeing them breaking the smaller
rocks and wondering how long can you do this for?
Right?
Can you just keep getting smaller and smaller rocks at some point?
Is it no longer rock?
And I imagine that people have been doing this for a long time.
I don't think I'm the first person to ever smash rocks together.
Right.
Um,
I think it's an old,
it's an old question.
It's a kind of question.
People have been asking themselves since people have been asking questions.
Right?
Um,
and if,
uh,
you know,
if particle physicists were superheroes,
this would be their origin story,
right?
Something like this.
This is,
uh,
the dawn of particle physics here.
Um,
okay.
And it's an important question,
but it's a difficult question to tackle,
right?
What is everything made out of?
It's a big question.
How do you approach that?
Well,
in science,
our strategy when we are tackling something very big and very difficult is try
the dumbest thing first.
Okay.
Just do the simplest,
most obvious thing first.
That doesn't work.
Try the second dumbest thing or extrapolate from it a little bit,
right?
So what's the simplest approach to answering this question?
What is everything made out of?
Well,
you might just try a list,
right?
Look around you and literally say what's in the universe,
Okay.
So your list might look something like this,
right?
The university has me,
it has you.
And as a,
you know,
this rock,
the other rock that are the rock over there,
right?
Um,
and this list,
this is a pro approach.
Using a list is gonna have a lot of problems,
right?
Problem number one is the universe has a lot of rocks in it.
So your list is going to be super duper long,
right?
And you guys like thinking about lists and organizations,
you might also wonder like,
well,
it's the illest exclusive or inclusive,
you know,
cause if it's inclusive,
then I have to have all the things in the list also in this list on the list.
You know,
there's lots of problems there.
Um,
the other problem with a list approach is that the universe has more than just
rocks in it,
right?
For example,
as you look around you and you discover the universe is full of all sorts of
crazy,
interesting things,
right?
There's Ross with is also air and there's water in this fire and this
blueberries and I iPhones,
right?
And the more you look around,
the more you sort of impressed and staggered by the incredible complexity of the
world we live in,
right?
Uh,
for example,
you know,
there's puppies and bicycles and strangely muscular fellows to become governor
of California,
right?
The world is really full of interesting stuff,
and that's one of the things that makes it a nice word to live in,
right?
You wouldn't want to live in the world.
That's just rocks,
right?
For example.
Um,
and it also highlights,
uh,
what's the,
a problem with this approach,
right?
Is that the list isn't really an answer.
If you ask me what is the world made out of,
Daniel?
And I literally gave you a list that had everything in the universe on it that
wouldn't really feel like an answer to your question,
right?
It's like asking a teenager,
where are you going?
And they say out,
okay,
well it's an answer,
but it's not really an answer to the question,
right?
It's not a satisfying answer.
So what kind of satisfying answer would you like?
You'd like something that reveals something about the world.
Something explains all this incredible complexity in terms of something simpler,
right?
You want to peel back a layer of reality and reveal the simpler set of building
blocks to explain all of this complexity.
So how do we do that?
Well,
we have this dumb list,
right?
So let's try the second most dumb approach,
which is organize our list,
right?
So we categorize things and we say,
well,
this stuff over here is all the rock like and this stuff over here is plant
like,
and you can argue whether Arno belongs in the rock category or the living thing
category,
right?
Everything belongs into category somewhere.
We're scientists about it.
And you start to notice patterns.
So you organize,
you make a list,
you organize it,
you notice patterns,
you ask questions about those patterns because those patterns are your clues
there.
The roadmaps that tell you what's going on underneath,
why are there so many rock like things and why do these things all similar,
right?
There must be some pattern there.
Okay,
so we've done that and a fast forward a few hundred years or a few thousand
years depending on whether you give the Greeks any credit for this kind of stuff
and you get to the periodic table of the elements and you guys might be
thinking,
we're smart people.
He's a particle physicist.
Why are we talking about high school chemistry,
right?
Periodic tables,
high school chemistry.
Well,
it is high school chemistry.
It's also,
in my view,
one of the most staggering achievements in human intellectual history.
Why?
Because it's taken us from an almost infinite complexity of stuff down to a
hundred building blocks from those hundred building blocks.
You can make anything that you've ever touched or tasted or driven over or
anything,
right?
Anything any human has ever interacted with has been made.
Out of these hundred building blocks.
If our goal is to simplify the universal reveal,
a simpler nature underneath this is a huge step forward already,
right?
And this is hundreds of years ago.
So it's,
it's sort of incredible and it makes you wonder like,
why is it even possible?
Why is it possible that we live in it?
Why do we live in a universe where it's possible to describe complexity in terms
of simple stuff,
right?
It means something deep.
It means that all the complexities and the arrangements,
right?
Not In the objects themselves,
it's reminds me of something else,
right?
It's like the universe is organized by the Lego principle.
Write that out of a few basic building blocks.
You can build anything.
You can use the same basic building blocks to build dinosaurs,
right?
Or to build a pirates,
Or like dinosaur pirates,
right?
It's incredible that anything can be made out of these building blocks.
Um,
and to me it's interesting because it seems like if you were caveman or
cavewoman physicists,
right?
And you are asking this question for the first time,
you might consider various options.
Maybe the world is not made out of basic building blocks.
Maybe it's infinitely divisible is smaller and smaller pieces using an
infinitely sharp knife,
right?
Could have been,
or maybe instead of having a simpler small set of building blocks,
maybe the number of building blocks could have mirrored the number of things,
right?
And you could have had,
for example,
you know,
cats are made out of cat particles and cartoonists made out of cartoon particles
and Lomb has made out little Lama Leno's or whatever you call those particles,
right?
That's certainly could have been.
And if you're the first person asked this question,
you'd have to consider every possible idea cause you have no rules about how the
universe works,
right?
But nothing that you see around you is a basic building block of the universe,
And we don't look,
we don't just list the periodic table of the elements and say,
we're done.
All right,
we start,
we don't just list the elements.
Say we're done.
We organize our knowledge,
right?
So we group it into the periodic table.
The elements after all,
there are patterns here.
That's why we call it the periodic table of the elements.
Okay.
All right.
I could see the Jorge's getting boards cause he's playing tetris theory.
Um,
but there are patterns here,
right?
And if our goal is to reveal one more layer of truth to reveal the simpler
structure that underlies it,
we have to look for patterns.
And so I'm not a chemist,
but you know,
I know that in the periodic table,
these guys over here on the right side are not very active.
And there's these guys over here on the left are very active in the middle you
have these metals,
right?
And and all sorts of stuff.
And there are patterns in the periodic table and these patterns are in fact the
clues,
right?
They tell us what's underneath the periodic table.
And we know now of course,
because they're all taking a high school chemistry,
that all the patterns and the periodic tables are just emergent phenomena from
the structure of the atom,
right?
They were in fact clues that points at his down to reveal what the,
the nature of the atom was.
And you know,
the reason that these guys are noble and these guys are not noble and the the
metals are the way they are is because of this structure.
It's because the electrons fill up their orbital shells and don't like to play
games anymore,
is because of the number of protons in the atom determines the element that you
are.
So all of the chemical properties are just clues that pointed to the structure
of the atom itself,
right?
And so we can look to those clues to tell us how to understand a deeper level of
reality right down below the Hula Hoop level.
Okay.
But remember,
as we're exploring the universe,
that nothing that you know is a building block of the universe.
Nothing you've played with the chairs,
you're sitting on the Lama you wrote to work on or had the tornadoes.
None of these things are basic building blocks of the university.
University is built out of deeper,
weird or strange things that have no analog in your life,
right?
Not even strange combinations of things like Llama tornadoes can explain the way
the universe works.
You know,
we like to use intuitive ideas like particles which are little spinning balls or
waves,
which we know about from things.
Or maybe light is a particle and a wave,
right?
In reality,
the basic building blocks of the universe are totally alien to us.
We can try to understand them using these analogies,
but in the end they do.
They don't really work.
Okay,
so let's zoom in a little bit and understand the current state of knowledge.
Or we had the atom,
which has protons and neutrons and electrons whizzing around that of course,
right?
And inside the Proton and neutron or corks.
So the UPC cork and the down quark,
you put two up corks in a down course together to make a proton to down corks
and up core together to make a neutron.
Right?
And that means something sort of astounding.
It means with just these three particles,
up corks and down quarks to make your protons and neutrons.
And then to complete the Adam,
you can build any Adam,
any item can be built at a three particles and those and anything can be built
out of atoms,
which means anything you've ever tasted or stepped on or interacted with can be
made out of just three particles.
That's incredible simplification,
right?
From infinite complexity down to three particles.
It means the recipe for building literally anything is certain number of,
of corks,
certain number of down quarks,
electrons mix,
right?
That's literally the recipe for everything in terms of simplification.
That's pretty impressive.
So you might be thinking,
wow,
we went from infinity to a hundred to three.
We're like on the verge of figuring this out,
right?
The trajectory is pretty good.
If these guys had come next week and they'd be showing us the one particle that
rules them.
All right.
Um,
so we're not quite there.
And the point of the book is to explain to you the wrinkles in this story cause
the wrinkles are really interesting.
Okay.
So first of all,
one wrinkle is we don't just have these three particles.
We found these three particles,
but there are more particles.
Okay.
The Up Cork and the down cork,
or two examples of corks,
but there are other corks.
There's the charm cork,
this strange cork,
the top cork and the bottom core.
Okay?
I'm not making these names up.
Okay.
I wish somebody had asked me.
I would've come up with Steven sillier names.
The Electron is an example of a part of what we call the left on and this six of
those as well.
Okay?
So we have not just three particles that make up matter.
We have these 12 particles that we've discovered.
So what do we do in science?
When we were confused,
we didn't know what to do.
Well,
first we just make a list,
then we organize it,
right?
So now the current state of knowledge is this a new periodic table?
It's a periodic table of the fundamental particles,
right?
And what we try to do is place all of these particles in a table so we can
understand how they fit together.
Maybe get some clues,
which will lead us to ask questions that will reveal an even deeper layer of,
of the universe.
So we have the UPC cork and the down Cork,
which,
you know,
these make the protons and neutrons together with the,
they explain everyday matter.
But in this first column we also include this particle called the Neutrino.
Neutrinos are really strange,
mysterious particle sometimes called a subatomic particle that's not really
accurate because it's not inside the atom.
Um,
but it's a mysterious particle,
but it's also everywhere.
For example,
there are 100 billion neutrinos passing through my fingernail every second 100
million and your fingernails as well,
right?
So why are we not like getting beaten down by all of these neutrinos is they
pass right through it without even noticing.
We don't notice them.
They don't notice us.
Right?
It's like that guy who lives down the hall from you.
You don't even like make eye contact,
right?
Totally.
Just pass right through each other.
Uh,
so neutrinos ignore us and we ignore them.
Um,
there's so many neutrinos because there are being produced by the sun,
but it's a clue that a lot of the things that are happening in the universe all
around you,
you're not privy to,
you can't see.
You can immediately detect,
okay,
the universe is different from the universe that you experience.
So we put all of these four in the same column.
And the interesting thing is about the 12 is that there seem to be copies of
each other,
right?
So for example,
the charm cork and the top cork,
we put them in the same row as the UPC cork because they are copies of the
upwork,
the exact,
exactly the same properties,
the same chart,
that same charge,
the same interactions,
the same spin.
All of these things are the same except the charm and the top are heavier than
the upwork.
Okay?
Why are they there?
Why does the upwork cork had these like weird to secret heavy cousins,
right?
Nobody knows the charm.
Quark is much heavier than the upwork.
The top Cork is the heaviest fundamental particle we've ever discovered.
It's thousands and thousands of times heavier than the upwork.
It's like the upworks corks,
secret fat country cousin.
The can't even leave the house,
right?
It's like shins snapping the fat.
This one,
um,
it's also easily offended.
So the fascinating thing is that not only are there two copies of the UPC cork,
this two copies of the downtown core,
the strange and the bottom had the same relationship.
They're perfect copies of the down quark,
all the same properties except heavier,
right?
The electron also has these copies,
does the [inaudible],
which is just a heavy version of the electron.
And then the Tao,
which is an even heavier version of the new on this,
even three of these neutrinos,
right?
So we have these really interesting patterns that form when you start to
organize our knowledge of the periodic table of the fundamental particles.
What does it mean?
Well,
I hope that it means that there's something deeper going on.
Currently.
We have no idea,
but we have some fun questions,
right?
The patterns give us questions and we hope those questions will lead us to the
answers.
Okay.
So what questions do we have?
Well.
Question number one,
why do we have all these particles?
You only need three to make all of matter,
right?
Why 12 are there in fact,
12 or they're 24,
24 billion according to theorists,
there's no limit on the number of particles.
And you could have in a fundamental theory,
right?
Um,
how many particles are there?
Why did the particles each have two copies?
To me,
this is a really interesting deep question because I like thinking about
numbers,
right?
One of the fundamental goals of physics is to explain the whole universe in a
simple equation.
How do you know when that,
when you're done,
when the equation is simple enough?
Well,
the standard people often use is if it could fit on a tee shirt,
okay?
If you can put all of physics on a single t shirt,
then you're done.
Imagine we were there and you're looking at that equation and there's a numbered
right?
Five.
That means that five is a deep,
important number somehow in the universe,
right?
All right,
so numbers are important.
Now we look at this table,
we see there's three copies of every particle,
right?
Why three,
If you ask theorists and mathematicians,
what kind of numbers do you expect in a fundamental theory?
All they have strong opinions,
right?
Zero.
That's an okay.
Number one,
you can have tie.
Shirt Pi's a good number,
right?
No,
but he says three,
right?
Unless they're Catholic.
Also right
through like why is three is the number three somehow important to the universe?
It seems to me like either it is or it's a clue.
Right?
Then in a thousand years or 100 years,
people are going to look back and say,
that was such an obvious clue that blah,
blah,
blah.
Whatever secret of the universe hasn't been revealed to us yet.
Right.
Is staring them in the face.
If I had been a physicist,
then I totally want to figured it out.
Right?
It's one of those screaming clues.
That way we just don't know what it means right now.
We just know it's a clue.
Right?
Another big mystery about these particles is the relationship of the masses.
We know that in general,
they tend to have more mass as you go this direction,
but there's no pattern to the masses.
The Higgs Boson,
if you know anything about it,
explains how the particles get mass,
but it doesn't tell you why this one got a lot of mass and this one got almost
none,
right?
There's no explanation for that at all.
And the ratios are crazy.
The top quark is thousands of times heavier than any of the other particles.
It's,
it's,
it's really strange.
Um,
but one of my favorite ones is this one about the charges of the particles.
So the electronic charge of minus one,
sort of by definition,
um,
but the quirks of these really strange fractional charge,
it's like two thirds minus one third,
right?
How's that even possible?
A fractional charge.
Well that's just because of how you define that,
the charge of the electron.
But the interesting thing is about the ratios.
These guys add up two thirds,
two thirds,
one third to make plus one a proton,
which perfectly balanced is the electron,
right?
Well,
that's convenient because you need that exact balance to have neutral atoms.
And to have physics and chemistry and biology and silly physics books and free
lunch in the cafe or at all,
that stuff rests on this perfect balance.
But in our theory,
that's a perfect coincidence.
We have two knobs in the theory,
the charge of the electron and the Charter of the corks.
And if you're the control panel of the universe,
you could set those things to be anything and you still get a valid theory of
physics.
So why do they balance perfectly well either it's a huge monster,
cosmic level coincidence and not an almost coincidence like the moon and the sun
being the same size in the sky.
So you get an eclipse,
but a perfect exact coincidence.
Okay,
that's strange,
right?
That's a clue.
But our current theory,
we say no,
there's no relationship,
right to arbitrary numbers.
To me,
it's possible that there's a simpler explanation,
right?
That these things are actually built out of the same smaller set of Lego blocks,
which would explain why they have a perfect balance in their and their charges.
But currently we have no idea what that explanation is and we don't.
Just like thinking about how the particles,
we also like thinking about how they talk to each other,
right?
The forces they feel when they come into into play.
And before Jorge was the favorite cartoonists for particle physicist,
we had Richard Fineman who came up with a Fineman diagram,
sort of a cartoony way of thinking about physics.
And he thought about the way particles interact with each other by drawing these
diagrams.
And so the straight lines or particles moving and the wiggly lines are particles
talking to each other and we can use his calculations and this strategy to
predict the results of experiments.
And you've ever worked in an experimental lab,
you know that if you predict an experimental result and you get within like a
factor of two,
you're like wow,
it all,
it works science.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Well,
we can predict the results of experiments and get the results to agree with the
theory to 10 decimal places,
10 decimal places.
It's incredible precision.
So the theory we have about how the particles talked to each other works super
duper well.
Right.
It almost makes you think if you're a conspiracy theorist that like maybe we are
living in a simulation and we've uncovered the source code of the universe.
You know,
maybe this is how the cow in the universe does the calculations to decide what
an electron is supposed to do,
right?
Because this doesn't happen by random that you get this level of agreement by
random chance.
It'd be like hitting a golf ball in New York and getting a hole in one in China.
Okay.
It just doesn't happen by chance.
But we don't measure our particle theory just by how well does it work?
Like does it predict experiments?
Remember,
we want a really simple theory.
We want to simplify the universe.
So let me show you the current state of the art and thinking in particle
physics.
This is the Lagrangian that describes the standard model of particle physics.
Okay.
And you know,
in my estimation,
it doesn't quite yet fit on a tee shirt.
In fact,
only half of the terms could fit on the screen.
Um,
so we're not quite there yet.
We have a lot of questions left about how these particles talk to each other.
Um,
but that's not the end of the story.
That's not even the biggest problem in particle physics,
right?
So first I want you to go away with a feeling of like,
wow,
there are a deep,
basic questions about how particles work that we don't know,
right?
We're standing,
we've made a lot of progress,
but we're staring into the abyss and we feel like in a thousand years people
will look back and think,
wow,
those things were really obvious or a wish they knew this,
or how could they not have figured that out?
Right?
Well,
it turns out all of those questions are a tiny fraction of the questions we have
about the universe because the particles I've introduced you to in the everyday
matter than you familiar with and everything that makes up me and you and
hamsters and stars and dust and planets only accounts for a tiny fraction of the
universe.
All of that effort,
understanding matter only explains a little sliver of what the universe is
actually made out of,
right?
So all that great progress then,
you know,
divided by 20.
So it turns out that only 5% of the universe is this kind of stuff,
right?
So we've measured very precisely the fraction of stuff in the universe.
That's our kind of stuff.
And that's 5%.
The rest of it is a big mystery,
right?
The rest of the stuff in the universe,
we don't really have any idea what this kind of stuff is.
So it's an incredible moment in physics and moment.
I call it precision ignorance,
when we've measured very precisely that we don't know very much about the
university.
And that's exciting because it means we have a lot of things left to discover.
So how is it possible that we could know that we know very little about the
universe?
Right?
How does that exactly work?
Well,
let me tell you a little bit about it.
Uh,
the first part of the story begins with Galaxy Spinning.
So somebody sent their Grad student out to look at galaxies and understand how
they spin.
And if you want to think about galaxies,
a good model is to think about,
um,
a merry go round with a bunch of ping pong balls on it.
What happens if you spin that merry go round?
Well,
the ping pong balls are going to fly out,
right?
Unless there's some force holding them in.
So in the case of galaxies that forces gravity keeps all the stars from flying
out of the edge of the,
of the,
of the galaxy.
So you can do something interesting,
which is measure how fast the galaxy is spinning and then count up all the stars
and ask,
is there enough gravity to keep all the stars in based on how fast they're
spinning?
So somebody sent their Grad student off,
make sure this works.
You know,
make these two measurements.
Make sure they agree.
And what they discovered is that the galaxies are spinning much,
much faster than they should be able to.
Galaxy spinning that fast should be throwing their stars out into inner space
all the time because there isn't nearly enough gravity to hold them in when
they're spinning that quickly.
This is a really perplexing results.
For a long time people didn't understand it and they thought,
well,
maybe you mismeasured how the galaxies are spinning or you miss counted the
stars or something is crazy.
And then eventually people thought,
well,
maybe there's something else in those galaxies.
Maybe there's some sort of new invisible thing cause we don't see it that has a
lot of gravity to it,
right?
So you need something that's invisible and has gravity.
So they called it,
they didn't know what it was,
but they call it dark matter.
And literally dark matter is the name of the theory.
It's also a summary of what we know about it,
right?
It's dark and it has mattered.
And that's basically what we know.
Okay.
That's the idea.
It's also what you know was the problem he was trying to solve.
Like there must be some sort of dark matter restuff to explain all of this.
Um,
so it was a big mystery for a long time.
But if you,
if you postulate the existence of a huge amount of invisible matter in these
galaxies,
it explains why they're spinning so fast.
But to understand how dark matter is dark,
we have to spend a moment thinking about how particles interact.
So we say dark matter is dark because it doesn't give off light.
It doesn't reflect light the way planets and stars do,
right?
That means it doesn't feel electromagnetism,
which is one of the four fundamental forces responsible.
The one responsible for light.
This also gravity,
which anything that has mass will feel,
gravity will attract itself.
Then there's the weak nuclear force and the strong nuclear force which are
responsible for holding the nucleus together and also radioactive decay.
So when we talk about dark matter and we know the dark matter feels gravity,
right?
Because that's how it was discovered.
It's basically,
uh,
you know,
explains the extra gravity we need for the galaxies to rotate.
We know it doesn't feel electromagnetism because if it did,
then we would have seen it,
right?
It doesn't feel the weak force and it doesn't feel as strong forest.
And as far as we know,
dark matter doesn't feel any other kind of force at all.
We've been trying to interact with dark matter in lots of ways.
Um,
but it never seems to respond even to our Facebook requests,
right?
All we know about dark matter is that it feels gravity.
It sort of defined by to be the thing that gives the extra gravity.
Um,
and so 5% of the universe is the stuff we know that we still have a lot of
questions about.
The fascinating thing about dark matter is that you need a lot of it to explain
how the galaxies are spinning.
It's not like,
oh,
you need 1% or 2%.
It's a little bit of a correction.
It's a mammoth correction.
You have to multiply the amount of matter in all the stars by a factor of five
to get enough gravity.
Explain how rapidly these galaxies are spinning.
It's a crazy idea,
right?
When we think of a new physics theory,
we like simplicity,
right?
Think of the simplest theory that explains your data.
Well,
if you're a theory requires an immense amount of invisible matter that permeates
the universe of nobody's ever discovered before.
Well maybe you go back and check your calculations right before you get that
published.
And it took people a long time to accept the idea of dark matter.
In fact,
it wasn't until people found other ways to see dark matter,
they really became convinced it was a thing and not a mistake.
Uh,
one really cool way to see dark matter is to see it acting as a lens in the sky.
So dark matter is invisible,
which means light passes through it,
but it has mass.
So it bends space and it can bend light as well.
Uh,
acting like a lens.
So imagine there's a huge blob of invisible dark matter between you and some
far,
far away galaxy.
What happens to photons leaving that galaxy?
Well,
a photon zooming off in one direction,
we'll get bent towards you by this blob of dark matter,
right?
A photon zooming off in another direction also gets bent towards you.
So what happens if you look out in the sky in two different directions?
You see the same galaxy two places in the sky,
right?
It looks just like a lens is acting somewhere in the sky.
In fact,
it's more than just duplication and actually gets distorted.
All sorts of interesting optical effects,
just like you would expect from a lens.
You can Google image,
search it later.
It's pretty awesome.
It's called gravitational lensing.
And when people saw this,
I thought,
well,
there must be some invisible stuff out there.
There really does have gravity to it.
It's pretty,
pretty spectacular discoveries.
And the last bit came from a collision.
Now I'm a particle physicist,
so when I want to solve a problem or understand something,
I smashed stuff together.
Okay.
That's like my modus operandi,
right?
Collide particles together and look to understand what's inside them.
If you want to understand galaxies,
that approach,
it doesn't really work,
right?
You can't say like go to the government and say,
I want funding to be able to galaxy collider.
Okay.
Even these days,
uh,
we don't have enough funding for science.
Um,
so we can't use all the signs,
finance,
Galaxy,
collider.
So an astrophysicist has a different approach.
Instead of building a collider,
they just look out into space and hope to find this experiment already
happening.
And fortunately they found one.
So the bullet cluster is a mammoth cluster of two mammoth collision of two
clusters of galaxies.
So a cluster of galaxies has both normal matter and dark matter in it.
So what happens when these two things slammed into each other?
Well,
the normal matter smashed into itself just like you would expect when two
planets collide in science fiction movies,
right?
Boom,
boom,
everybody runs away.
Um,
but the dark matter passes right through the normal matter.
Okay?
It's invisible.
It's also untouchable the way neutrinos are and it passes through.
The normal matter also passes through itself.
So just pass through itself to the other side.
So you get dark matter on either side and in the middle you have these big
explosions from normal matter.
That's really cool because it means that the normal matter was separated from
the dark matter.
And you can use gravitational lensing to see directly that the dark matter is
there,
right?
And the normal matter is still in the center.
So this is the way you can separate the two.
You can see that dark matter really is its own thing.
It's not just a weird miscalculation of gravity or new theory of gravity for
normal matter.
It's its own new kind of invisible stuff.
All right,
so the bullet cluster really was the nail in the coffin for all the other
theories that tried to explain dark matter and get ms people.
That dark matter really is a thing.
It's really out there.
Okay,
so what is dark matter?
Right?
We know that it's dark,
right?
We know that it's matter.
I mean it was a lot of it.
That mostly sums up what we think,
you know,
we don't know what it is.
We know that there's more of it than our kind of matter.
Now we're particle physicists.
So our work is this.
Our natural inclination is to explain the unknown in terms of the known.
So for example,
one of the favorite theories about what is dark matter is,
well maybe dark matter is made out of particles just like we are made out of
particles,
right?
And the favorite theory is called a weakly interacting massive particle,
Wimp.
And that's one of the favorite theories.
Another one is,
well,
maybe it's this big blobs of matter out of the space.
It's called a massive astrophysical compact halo object right now if there is
called the Macho,
okay?
So even in science we have the wimps versus the machos,
right?
These are two ideas,
but they're sort of extrapolations from what we know,
right?
Um,
and is dangerous to extrapolate to a quarter of the universe from a tiny,
probably atypical sliver that you've been studying for hundreds of years,
right?
So we should keep that in mind.
Um,
and the other thing to remember is that dark matter isn't out there in the
universe.
Dark matters everywhere.
Dark matters here in this room,
okay?
I have dark matter in my hands right now.
It passes right through us.
I can hold it or contain it,
but it's here with us.
It's not like out there somewhere.
Um,
maybe dark matter's a totally new kind of matter.
Maybe it's not even made out of particles,
right?
Or maybe it's made out of a whole new kind of particles the way we are,
Many different kinds of particles.
So maybe this complex,
dark matter,
physics,
chemistry,
dark matter of biology,
right?
For All we know there could be dark matter life right here in this room with us,
And if you were dark matter life,
you wouldn't think of us as normal matter,
right?
We're the little sliver 5% you could almost round away and your understanding of
the universe in some dark matter of physics classes,
a professor saying,
yeah,
we understand 96% of the universe except for this little weird sliver,
right?
Um,
so maybe there are dark matter tourists,
right?
So 5% of the universe is explained by the particles.
We have some clue about 27% of the universe is dark matter,
right?
We know it's there.
We don't know very much about it.
That's still is.
Two thirds of the universe is budget a totally unaccounted for,
right?
Um,
no accounting firm is going to accept that.
So what is the rest of this pie while the rest of this pie is filled by
something called dark energy?
Okay.
But dark energy is really science code for we are totally clueless.
How about the rest of the universe?
Because the truth is,
and until 20 years ago,
we didn't even know that we were clueless about this part.
Okay.
And now don't be confused.
Dark energy and dark matter have no relationship other than literally the word
dark.
Okay?
That's the only connection between the two theories.
So how do people even figure out that dark energy was a thing?
Well,
people were thinking,
thinking about the history of the universe.
Okay?
So if you know of a physics,
here's a brief summary of the history of the universe.
Okay.
So first you had the big bang,
right?
And all this stuff in the universe exploded out.
And then,
you know,
interesting stuff happened and people were wondering what's going to come next?
So is there enough gravity in the stuff in the universe for things to slow down,
turn around,
and then come back into a big crunch?
Okay.
That was one possible explanation for the history of the universe.
Uh,
the future of the universe.
Another possibility is that there wasn't enough stuff in the initial explosion,
not enough gravity to,
to turn things around.
And it was just,
just Griff drift out.
Gradually slowing down,
cooling off till the universe cools off and spreads out into something that
known affectionately as the heat death of the universe.
Okay.
And now,
not a cozy time,
but these were the two possible theories of people who are considering the big
crunch or the heat death of the universe.
So they said,
well,
let's measure it.
Let's go out and look,
see if things are speeding up or uh,
see how much things are slowing down.
So it turns out the universe preferred secret option C,
which is neither of these ideas,
right?
Which to me is like the best case in science when you discover something that
nobody expected to be the answers,
right?
So they went out and they measured it and they discovered that actually what's
happening is that it's not slowing down at all.
It's expanding faster and faster.
It's accelerating in its expansion.
Right.
That's crazy.
Nobody even thought about that as an idea because to accelerate the size of the
universe requires some sort of force,
right.
Which requires some sort of energy and the amount of energy that would be
required.
Well,
that'd be like two thirds of all the energy in the universe,
right?
That would be totally crazy.
In fact,
that's what's happening.
And we have no idea why.
Right?
We know that it's happening and we measured it.
We see that the universe is expanding faster and faster every year.
We just don't know why.
Right?
What could possibly be responsible for accelerate for pushing galaxies,
a boy from each other?
I mean,
galaxies are heavy,
right?
Hundreds of billions of stars in them.
Stars are not tiny objects.
What could be responsible for pushing all of these galaxies,
uh,
apart from each other,
right?
We have no idea,
which means that we have no idea whether it's going to turn around or whether
it's going to continue or whether it's going to increase.
Right?
But it is a fascinating and consequence to it.
The space between us and other galaxies is growing at faster than light can
traverse that space.
What does that mean?
It means that these galaxies are gonna move out beyond our visible horizon.
Right?
So every year that you look up at the night sky,
it's going to get darker and darker and darker.
So imagine doing astrophysics and 10 billion years,
right?
If human civilization survives the next three years,
Or until the next election.
Um,
so imagine in 10 billion years we're trying to rebuild human astrophysics,
right?
And people are looking at it in the sky and wondering where does everything
Or is there anything out there they can be looking up into a totally black sky,
which case they would have no clue about how things work.
All the critical information that we learned from looking at the stars,
they would be totally ignorant of.
Now,
before you feel like too great about the fact that we are are living,
now we can use the stars to help us understand the universe.
Remember,
we're 14 billion years into the history of the universe already.
If we had evolved 10 billion years ago and looked up at the night sky,
then what would it have revealed to us that's now totally gone and lost forever?
Well,
we have no idea,
right?
So the future of the history,
the future of the universe is something we don't understand,
right?
It's not something we can predict because we have no understanding of the
mechanism by which the universe is expanding.
And it's only recently that we've even understood that it is expanding.
Right?
So that's why I say where at a special moment in physics,
who he's very recently figured out exactly how little we know about the
universe,
which means that we have an opportunity to learn something about it.
Okay?
So here's a pie chart to summarize our knowledge of the universe,
right?
Most of the universe is something we just don't understand that.
All right?
We labeled the dark energy so we can write grants about it.
The sound cool,
but really we have no clue what this thing is.
There are some ideas.
People come up with theoretical explanations for work.
Dark energy might be,
and they do calculations and they compare those to what we see and they're off
by 10 to the 100.
Okay?
There's only like 10 to the 80 particles in the universe.
So tend to the 100 is a huge,
um,
huge mistake.
Uh,
27% of the universe is dark matter is something we know it's there.
We know it's matter.
We don't have really anything else about it.
Is it one particles had lots of particles.
Is it something else?
Totally weird.
We don't know the rest of the universe,
this little corner,
this 5% the et cetera part of the universe.
That's me and you and ice cream and bicycles.
Okay.
We are really the,
the little bits of the universe.
And so you might think,
well how,
uh,
how are we in,
in making progress in understanding this question about what is the universe
where it's sort of like,
imagine somebody told you to understand elephants,
then you spend 300 years only studying the tail,
not even realizing there was more to the story.
Right?
And then one day finally somebody walks around to the front like,
excuse me,
maybe you want to like look at the rest of the elephant,
right?
Well,
what are you going to do in that situation?
How are you going to feel confident in understanding the rest of the elephant?
Right?
Well,
what you're probably going to do is say,
well,
maybe the rest of the elephant is made out of tails also.
Right?
Or like I can describe the elephant as a linear combination of tales that I
already understand,
right?
Because you're going to cling to the theories,
you know?
Right.
Well,
you might think that's ridiculous and it's absurd.
It's obviously a stupid thing to do.
That's exactly the same argument I made 10 minutes ago about dark matter,
right?
Maybe dark matters also made out of particles,
Because that's all we know.
So we should be careful and extrapolating our knowledge to the rest of the
universe.
It's a,
it's a great tendency and physics to extrapolate from the known into the
unknown,
but it's also dangerous when you're extrapolating from an unrepresentative
sliver.
So I don't mean to be depressing.
What I mean to do is to encourage you and to think about the kinds of things we
might be thinking about in the future.
Because this is a special moment.
If physics,
when you realize that you don't know very little,
it's a chance you have to reboot to throw away everything you thought you knew
and think,
you know what?
Maybe we're looking at unrepresentative slice.
We need to come up with some crazy new ideas,
right?
It's those moments when you know,
you know very little.
They give you the opportunity to totally like come up with something completely
new that could blow your mind,
right?
And in 200 years or in 500 years,
children's books about the universe will contain fax.
That to us are crazy.
Then we wouldn't even believe,
right?
Imagine giving this talk to Isaac Newton,
Staggering genius in the history of human physics.
He had no idea about any of this stuff and it would totally blow his mind.
How can we take anything he said?
Seriously,
right?
He had no clue about the cosmic situation.
The way we think about primitive caveman.
It's the way future scientists will think about us.
At least we know that we don't know very much about the universe,
right?
Which gives us a heads up or a way to get started.
So we know that we don't know very much about the universe.
However,
it is an exciting time because at the same time as we know that we're clueless,
we're also building awesome new tools to help us solve these mysteries.
So we have the large Hadron collider smashes particles together and try to see
what's inside them.
We have the gravitational wave observatory is that can see ripples in space and
time and black holes colliding billions of years ago,
which is pretty awesome.
We have space telescopes which would help us look back in the early moments of
the universe and figuring out these questions about how things got started or
what happened before the big bang.
And the,
hopefully in the future we will have even cooler technologies maybe given to us
by our alien friends.
So I,
um,
I like to think that this is an amazing period in physics that in the next five
years or 10 years or 15 years,
we will make some of these discoveries answered some of these questions and they
will really,
um,
maybe be a turning point in the history of physics.
I hope that in a hundred years people think back and think,
wow,
I wish I had been a physicist back in 2020.
And when they really figured out whatever it is we're about to figure out,
you know,
I like to think about the discovery of quantum mechanics,
right?
All those experiments people did over,
like of course,
of 10 years or so,
people just sat down and thought about it and figured it out and revealed what
the true nature of the universe was.
And I sometimes think if I had been around then I totally would've figured it
out.
Right?
But when you're standing at the forefront of human knowledge,
right?
Not knowing which direction to go,
any of these possible crazy ideas could be true.
It's not easy to know which direction is correct.
Right?
So in hindsight it might be obvious,
but here we are and not knowing much about the universe.
So to round out our tour a silly charts about the universe and to impress on you
how little we understand about the universe,
right?
This bit here is dark energy,
Most of the universe is something totally not understandable to us,
right?
This bit here,
dark matter is something we're pretty sure it's matter,
but that's about all we know.
And this little bit is me,
you and dark chocolate.
And so in our book we talk about this one question,
what is the universe made enough?
Because it's one of these deep and ancient questions that we think can be
answered and will be answered.
And when it is,
we'll change the way we think about the universe.
But there are lots of these questions in science,
big,
deep,
ancient questions with answers,
right?
Questions like what happened before the Big Bang,
Nobody knows the answer to that question.
Even the early moments of the big bang or is still a mystery or even more basic
questions like what is space?
You know,
you might think,
well,
that's obvious.
Space's emptiness,
right?
It's just the abstract backdrop on which things happen.
Well,
we know now that that's not true because we know the space can expand.
I mean,
those space can bend space can even ripple.
Okay.
Emptiness cannot ripple.
So space is not just engineers.
It's a thing that we live in.
It's like as if we were fish and we've been swimming and water for thousands of
years,
not even realizing the water was a thing.
We just thought it was,
you know the thing we were,
we're in,
right?
And then you discover,
oh,
it's a dynamical thing with properties,
right?
Space.
It's like that.
It might even have strange phases and we haven't even explored,
we don't know basic things about space,
like how many dimensions are there?
Well,
there's three that we're familiar with.
Robot string theory predicts 11 or 26 and there's lots of ways that it could be.
It could be extra little curled up loops of dimensions that were not even
familiar with.
So really basic,
ancient questions about the universe have not been answered,
but they have answers,
right?
These answers that can be revealed.
So we talk about all of those in the book and the point of our book and our
presentation today is not to convince you the science doesn't know anything.
It's just to show you the science will make great discoveries in the future and
to prepare you for those by introducing you to our cosmic level of ignorance.
So thanks very much for your attention.
So we're right up at the end of our allotted time,
but I think we can take a couple of questions if anyone has any.
And then afterwards,
uh,
Daniel and Jorge had been kind enough to do a book signing and stick around and
answer any other crazy questions you have.
Uh,
no questions.
Oh,
here we go.
Here's some questions.
Just mine.
Hi.
Thanks for giving us a great talk.
Thank you.
Are there any questions in the bus in this book that you would have liked to
explore but did not nice to fit in the book?
Yeah,
there are a lot of questions that we don't have the answer to that.
We also didn't talk about it in the book.
Um,
in the book we try to limit ourselves to questions that we thought people could
understand without any scientific background,
like simple,
deep questions.
For example,
a lot of people ask us,
why didn't you talk about the mysteries of Neutrino Oscillations in the book?
Holding the Trina is are interesting,
but it takes you to,
you know,
like it's like a 20 minute explanation for why they're interesting.
So we tried to focus on things that were very accessible.
Uh,
but you know,
there are other things like mysteries of quantum mechanics that would take a
whole other book.
Um,
cool.
Thank you.
So stay tuned for our next book.
I still have no idea.
Um,
which ones are your favorites individually?
I think one of my favorites is the question of what is space because it's not a
question you hear a lot of people even ask,
but I think it's really deep and important question.
I really liked writing that chapter because I like thinking about what space
was,
you know,
I first heard about like space expanding.
I was like,
what does that even mean?
It's like I understand each word individually,
but together it's like,
it doesn't make any sense.
Right?
Um,
so it's,
once you liberate yourself from the idea that space is an abstract idea and
discover there's a physical thing that you can think about how it changes and
moves,
it's a totally different way of thinking about the universe.
That was my fun.
My favorite one.
Yeah.
Uh,
my favorite,
uh,
a chapter 13,
you get the book,
it's a very special chapter.
Uh,
but now there's also a chapter I really like called a bad cosmic race sign.
And I like it because it's a very,
very specific mystery.
Like we're,
uh,
like Dana mentioned,
we're being bombarded by particles all the time.
Uh,
and there are some,
especially there are interesting because they're super,
super high energy.
Like,
there's super duper high energy we're being shot at by these particles and
nobody really knows where they're coming from or what could be making them.
Like there's no process in nature or astrophysics or physics that scientists
know about or could even imagine could be producing these super high energy
particles.
And so the possibilities are like insane.
Like there could be some totally new thing in the years nobody has ever seen
before or it could be like aliens shooting at us.
Um,
uh,
so it's,
it's pretty,
it's a pretty cool,
uh,
mystery.
Hi.
Thank you for the talk.
Wasn't there a theory that our universe,
uh,
starts with a big band and crunches and then big button again and what happened
to that theory if we're expanding now?
Great question.
Yeah.
So there was a theory that sort of a cyclical universe,
big bang,
big crunch,
Big Bang,
right?
Um,
the theory is less popular now because of dark energy because we know that the
universe is expanding like crazy.
So it's,
but we don't know what dark energy,
uh,
holds for the future.
Dark energy,
for example,
only turned on about 5 billion years ago.
So for a long time that the university just sort of coasting and slowing down
and then it turned on what's going to happen in the future,
they might turn around and make a big crunch.
So big crunch is still a possibility.
In fact,
there's a theory of space time called loop quantum gravity that says that maybe
all the spaces pixelated and these tiny tiny scale and it's specifically
predicts a big crunch.
So short answer is big crunch might still happen,
but nowhere in the near future.
So don't worry about it and you still have to pay next year's taxes.
But we know it.
Dark energy is such a mystery.
We can't predict what's going to happen because we don't understand the
mechanism for it at all.
Um,
yeah,
thanks for doing this talk.
This is awesome.
Uh,
so I think it's super important to have entertaining,
accessible examples of science,
especially for like young people to get them in stem and things
like that.
Are there other,
um,
resources or
organizations that you know of and that you support that you think
are really good,
uh,
to point to or to support monetarily?
Otherwise it's things like that.
Well,
first buy 10 copies of the book,
you can get them to young kids
or teenagers.
Uh,
it's a,
it's a good question.
Um,
I agree that science communication is important.
and um,
in fact it was a Google that partially inspired this because I was reading
Google put out at science comic,
uh,
technical comic about the development of the chrome browser.
Scott McCloud did it and you know,
like how to write a browser.
It's not like the going to be the top telling the top selling story on the New
York Times,
but it was a really compelling a comic.
It was really well done in terms of communicating something technical.
Um,
and so I'm seeing more and more of this like collaborations between scientists
and and uh,
and artists.
And I think not all scientists are good communicators,
which is fine.
You don't have to be good at everything.
But the important thing is to pair up with somebody who's a good communicator
and has artistic skills.
And I hope to see more of that in the future in terms of supporting those
causes.
That's a good question.
Um,
yeah,
there's a bunch of like in youtube channels that are really good and explaining
the science and things like that and just a lot of comic artists online doing
it.
Also,
I think they did what Daniel was saying.
Did I agree with a lot is the idea that uh,
I mean you guys are the ones kind of making this technology and pushing the
boundaries of science and engineering.
Um,
and so I really liked the idea of,
uh,
people in those positions kind of taking the initiative to not just do the
research but also think creatively and figure out new ways to communicate this
stuff out to people.
I mean,
there's a lot of these examples now,
but you know,
tomorrow somebody could come up with a totally different type of collaboration
or,
or a way to communicate
the stuff.
I saw a Higgs Boson dance performance once.
I'm not sure I learned much about science,
but it was entertaining.
Hello.
Are there any questions,
uh,
that you cannot conceive of a possible answer to?
So,
uh,
you know,
with dark energy you could start making up theories tomorrow and none of them
would be particularly well founded.
They'd likely be wrong.
But you know,
it,
it seems to me like you can conceive of what the answer might look like.
Um,
are there any questions where that's not true?
So for me,
one maybe is consciousness,
right?
So that's a great question.
A lot of the times the um,
we can speculate,
but our speculation exceeds the bounds of science.
So one example is,
you know,
what happened before the Big Bang?
Well,
it may be that all the information about what happened for the Big Bang was
destroyed in the big bang.
Right?
Um,
I will run,
never know.
Um,
one possible when one popular theory of the Big Bang,
the big bang was one of many and there's an infinite number of universes that
we're all created,
but then an hour now are separated from each other and moving away from each
other fast and the speed of light.
So we will never detect them.
That kind of theory is fun,
but it's basically philosophy because you can't ever test it.
So yeah,
there are a lot of questions like what happened before the Big Bang where we can
have ideas but it's not clear we'll ever be able to test them.
However,
science is always moving forward and things that used to be philosophy
questions,
right,
are now science questions because we develop new technologies and new ideas and
new clever ways to test these subtle theories.
Um,
that question you raised,
what is consciousness is sort of a favorite one of mine.
It's one that I think will actually never be testable by science,
um,
because science assumes consciousness.
So you can never step outside of it to probe that.
But that's a whole other topic.
Yeah,
that's a great question.
Hi,
thanks for the great talk.
I,
so I have a question about,
uh,
so how do you think,
um,
software engineers can contribute to perhaps answering some of these questions
and also how do you see machine learning company coming into the picture?
Wow,
great question.
We're doing a lot of machine learning these days and particle physics and in
astronomy because we have larger and larger datasets and more and more subtle
signals.
Uh,
so actually one of the things I personally research is how to use machine
learning tools to solve,
um,
particle physics problems.
Uh,
one thing you guys can do is hire more particle physicists.
I,
for example,
can discover here is one of my students and you now he works here at Google,
uh,
to,
you know,
make more connections between these two fields.
Cause you guys have a lot of awesome hammers and I'm always frustrated when I
see,
for example,
like,
oh,
Facebook spent,
you know,
$100 million on this tool to identify somebody's face in a picture.
You know,
it's like so much money is being spent on what seems to be like trivial problems
like a,
is there a cat in this Internet video?
You know,
so many Phd thesis has been written on that question,
right?
Which is like a great example of like a hard question,
but like,
who cares?
Right?
And we have hard questions where we actually care about the answer.
You know,
what is dark matter?
Is this a Higgs Boson?
Yes or no,
right?
Um,
so just like talk to scientists,
try to get them to explain their problem to you in terms of their language and
teach them your language.
And I think you'll find a lot of interesting overlap.
Um,
yeah.
On a cool project is can I tell them to have a cave crayfish?
Dreyfus.
Uh,
yeah.
So for example,
one project I'm working on is trying to understand these cosmic rays by turning,
um,
everybody's smartphone into a particle detector.
And then if you network all of these smartphones together,
you can build a global size telescope,
which could look out into space and see where maybe where these cosmic rays are
coming from.
It's called crayfish cosmic race found in smartphones.
I'm Haniya,
we certainly need a software help for that project.
So if you're really interested,
send me an email.
Do I think dark matter is more important than cats in videos?
Dark matter is cats and videos.
I think cats know something about dark matter.
They're not telling us.
It seems like every time we we get closer and closer and you can get an
announcer.
He was like,
oh no,
we have dark matter.
And then when we went down there,
oh now we have their guarantee.
Um,
cause now you have your pie chart of 5% is us.
But it wouldn't be surprised if 50 years from now,
oh no,
now we have an another dark thing.
So dark power or whatever.
Or now we know like darks.
Yeah.
So also 0.1% of the universe.
And so this is a question that I don't think has an answer,
but do you expect that to continue happening?
Especially also the other way around.
So now we have three particles,
but I wouldn't be surprised that then we have one and the womb,
I whole wrath of infant with new particles and we have a new,
a new table of fundamental,
fundamental fundamental particles and we'd go go like all the weight,
rabbit hole upwards and no one said,
Hey,
I love your question.
Um,
we express this question specifically in the book.
Okay.
The question is like,
we'll,
could there ever be a theory of everything like Cooley ever understand the
universe?
So,
um,
I hope not because I like asking questions.
Um,
but there,
there are some arguments that the university might have a smallest particle.
So one way to interpret your question might be,
could we ever drill down and discover the smallest particle or is it just going
to keep going forever?
Smaller,
smaller,
smaller particles,
right.
Well,
we don't know,
but there are some arguments that suggest that the universe has a small s,
uh,
a distance scale beyond which you cannot measure the university's pixelated.
It's some smallest level,
but there is an end to this.
Um,
the arguments are pretty weak.
They go like this.
If I take all of these numbers that I found about the universe,
the speed of light,
Planck's,
constant,
Newton's gravitational constant,
and I multiply them together in this creative way,
I get a number that has units of distance.
Okay.
That's called the Planck length.
What does that number?
Well,
it's 10 to the minus 35 meters.
Really,
really small.
Uh,
does that mean the universe is pixelated?
No.
Does it mean if the is pixelated?
It's pixelated at that size?
No.
But what do we do in science when we don't know what to do?
We do the dumbest thing first.
So that was the dumbest thing.
So it's sort of a hand waving argument that may be at that scale or somewhere
within a factor of a million of that scale.
The universe might be pixelated at the smallest level,
but that scale if 10 of the 15 smaller than what we can currently see.
So we're really far away from ever seeing that.
I mean you have to build like a solar system size particle collider to study
things at that small scale.
So I think it's likely that the universe is pixelated.
Though I don't have any hard evidence for it and that eventually we can figure
that out.
But it's a long way from now.
Thank you.
Great question though.
I mean even if we had the theory of everything,
the questions don't stop cause,
and you've got to ask like,
why is there three in that theory?
What does that mean?
Right?
Then philosophy takes over.
Hey,
thank you for the talk.
It was awesome.
Uh,
quick question.
Don't you think the first person see the Grand Canyon would have lived hundreds
of thousands of years ago?
Not a few hundred.
Yeah,
probably.
Um,
I mean 10 or 20 thousands of years ago,
it's a migration down from,
I have a science related question to what do you think,
uh,
we're going to figure out first dark matter and dark energy or a unifying model
of gravity and electromagnetism.
Do we need one for the other?
What do you think?
Well,
that's a great question.
Um,
we could figure out dark matter anytime in the next few years.
It's possible.
We're looking for dark matter very actively.
We're trying to create it in the lab by smashing particles together.
We're trying,
we have these big tanks of heavy water and just underground,
um,
that are looking for dark matter so we could discover it any moment,
right?
Or because keep looking for it and not find it.
So dark matter is the most likely thing to be discovered the next few years,
but also could be decades dark energy.
It's pretty exciting because it's such a big question.
Um,
and do we can make progress on that really unpredictably?
Uh,
it could be a long time,
a unifying theory of gravity and the other forces people that we're working on
that for decades and made very little progress.
So I don't expect that to be wrapped up anytime soon unless we could visit a
black hole and look inside of it.
Because inside a black hole is all the data we need to understand,
um,
why we don't have a grab a quantum theory of gravity.
If you've seen the movie interstellar,
that part of that movie was actually true.
The rest
we have no idea.
No idea.
Great question.
All right.
Well I think we're going to wrap up the Q and a now and then,
uh,
Daniel and Jorge will be signing books and answering any lingering questions for
the next while.
Thanks everybody.
Yeah,
thank you.